لا تزال اصداء تمرد مجموعه فاجنر تتردد
بقوه في روسيا وخارجها وخاصه ليتوانيا
التي تستعد لاستضافه القمه السنويه للحلف
خلال عشره ايام فقد حذر رئيسها من خطر
وجود مقاتلي فاجنان في بيلاروسيا على امن
المنطقه وكيف تقيم دول الحلف التطورات
الاخيره في روسيا وكيف تنظر موسكو الى خطه
الحلف وتعزيز وجوده العسكري على مقربه من
حدودها في الواقع ان القلق الاول كان
يتعلق ب لو ان هذا التمرد
والانقلاب الذي كان بالضبط لو انه نجح فما
الذي يمكن ان يسيطر على الاسلحه النوويه
هبوط روسيا في الفوضى يخشى منه بسبب رئيسي
وهو
سيطرتها على الاسلحه النوويه القلق الثاني
كان ما الذي يحصل في روسيا ميت تاثيرات
سيكون ذلك على مجريات الحرب هناك 60 كم
فجوه او فراغ بين ليليني غراد وفي روسيا
وبيلاروسيا ولو ان
البوليروس والروس قطعوا هذه المسافه
فان الدول البلطيق انذاك ستقطع وتبعد عن
بقيه دول الناتو ولذلك فان فلند وسويد
مهمان جدا بالنسبه للنيتو
لانهما سيساعدان في الدفاع عن دول البلطيق
وانتقال
الى بيلاروسيا وبالتالي
سيبقى امام قوات واجنر خلود مختلفه هناك
سيناريوهات معظم مقاتله
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ربما جزء منهم
يسير وراء
ينتقل الى بيلاروسيا ما يثير قلقا لديه
الغربيين
الى حرب اهليه وبالتالي خطر من الاسلحه
النوويه بيد من بيد اي متطرف ستقع هذه
الاسلحه هذا كان خطرا او تحديا يواجه
النيتو تعليق الغربيه سواء على لسان
مسؤولين او على لسان عديد الصحف ركزت على
ما اعتبرته اهانه حصلت بالنسبه لبوتين وان
المكانه التي كان يظن البعض انها له في
روسيا اتضح بانها غير صحيحه وبانه في وضع
ضعيف
جدا او ربما لا يفهمون ما هو الواقع
الروسي او ربما يريدون ان يصورون رغايبهم
واحلامهم في صيغه التعليقات على الاكس من
ذلك روسيا ابرت هذا الامتحان ما كانت
بوتين مرموقه مره اخرى اثبت بانه يستطيع
ان يدير الازمات وبنجاح المنظومه الروسيه
دوله كنظام اثبت بانه نظام حيوي وهناك
وحده في المجتمع
ولم يغدو اي شيء الذي كان قد وقفت روسيا
بخطوه واحده امام الحافه امام سيناريو
الفوضى
وهو نشوب فاحليه لم ياخذوا ذلك تقييم
العام اللي كان موجود عند نيته ودول
النيتو انه ما يجري في روسيا اولا شيئا
داخلي بمعنى ان هذه الدول لن تتدخل في
مجرياته ثانيا عبروا عن قلق
ومخاوفهم الامنيات وثالثا كانوا يفكرون
دائما بانه كيف يمكن مساعده اوكرانيا
لاستثمار ما يجري في روسيا من اجل ان تحقق
مكاسب ميدانيه
تساعدها في على طاوله المفاوضات لو ايضا
قام بعمليات قمع فانه ايضا سيخرج اقوى
ولكن المشكله انه يقاتل في حرب الكثير من
الناس في روسيا حسب رايي لا يهتمون بها
وبالتالي انا اعتقد نعم ستكون هذه بضعه
اشهر قلقه ومزعجه بالنسبه لروسيا ومجريات
حربها في اوكرانيا فلذلك
اعتقد انه من اصابه تخيل ان بريجوجن
سيشاركه قريبا في العمليه في اوكرانيا
طبعا هو الزداد الضروره لا يستغنون انه
خاصه اذا ناخذ في الاعتبار ان هناك طلبت
مقاطعه روسيه
على حدود اوكرانيا
الان غير محميه بصوره امام لديه وجهه نظر
فيما يتعلق بمطاع روسيا وهي تعتقد بان
روسيا تريد
توسع وهي تعتقد ان ايضا جزء من النخب في
هذه الدول الثلاث يعتقد ان مجرى ايضا
مسرحيه وانه كان هو فقط لنقل هؤلاء
المقاتلين من اجل زعزعات الاوضاع في
بولندا
وليتوانيا ان هناك يعني عدم تيقن عند دول
الناتو عن طبيعه ما جرى في روسيا او عن
طبيعه النوايا الروسيه فيما يتعلق بهذه
الدول على وجه التحديد وحتى فيما يتعلق
بالحرب على اوكرانيا النقاط الساخنه
موجوده فعلا وفي زمن واعتقد ان الناتو كان
يعي وجودها ولكن هناك اختلافات وتنوعات في
هذه النقاط الساخنه من السابق لاوانه
التخيل بان قوه البيلاروسيه والقوه
الروسيه في مثل هذه الظروف السياسيه
والجيوسير الذي العسكريه المؤقده ستقوم
بشن هجوم على دول البلطيغ او بولندا لان
بالفعل هناك
من حيث العدد وتقنيات لحلف الناتو من وجهه
النظر الاسلحه التقليديه فلذلك لا
تقوم روسيا بتنفيذ مثل هذه الخطوه قبل ما
تحل المشكله في اوكرانيا على ذلك روسيا
مهتمه الى عوده الى عياده العلاقات مع خلف
الناتو ووجود اي توازن بين خلف الناتو
وبين روسيا كما كان عليه في عام 1997
عندما تم توقيع لوقيفه الناتو روسيا ان
هناك سيكون محاوله حديثه من اجل الوضع
اوكرانيا على مسار الانضمام لحلف النيتو
لكن نحن ايضا نعرف بان مساله انضمام
اوكرانيا لحلف الناتو تحتاج الى سنوات كيف
ترى سيناريوهات المواجهه مستقبلا بين
روسيا وحلف الاطلس سيناريو الذي الاكثر
احتمالا هو تكون حاله ركود وجمود وحتى
وصول الى حرب مجان مجمده او وقف اطلاق نار
دون اي اتفاق حوله لن يتم قبول اوكرانيا
قريبا في حلف الناتو ربما سيتم اختراع
صيغه ما على شكل مثلا مجلس روسيا خلف
سيكون مجلس سحل في الناتو
واوكرانيا ولكن حلف الناتو لا يريدوا الان
ليس في مصلحته الدخول في صراعا مباشر مع
روسيا يعني انا اميل الى ان الامر يعتمد
على مدى التزام دول الناتو بامداد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح واي نوع من السلاح لكن
ان استمرت تزوير السلاح بهذه الطريقه انا
اميل الى سيناريو الجمود المؤلم للطرفين
واستمرار الاستنزاف الى ان يتوصلوا الى
نوع من الهدنه وليس حلا سياسيا بالمعنى
الشامل ما جرى من تمرد في في انا بتقدير
هو مظهر لازمه داخليه في روسيا لتصدع في
النخبه الحاكمه هو هو السؤال الصعب
بالنسبه لبوتين يعني ربما ياتي الوقت
قريبا عندما يسال المجتمع الروسي سيسال
سؤال الصعب لماذا ذهبنا الى اوكرانيا ماذا
حققنا وما هو الثمن